[Laughter]
so hey everybody we are here we are here
we're here and we've been drinking
already well come on i started drinking
15 20 minutes ago did you really yeah
okay you're way ahead of me then
i only just i've only had like three
sips that's all i had i was in here
trying to figure this [ __ ] out hopefully
everything i mean we're praying to the
streaming gods uh everything worked out
good on wednesday's show i think it did
yeah and uh yeah it did i think it's
worked i think i had like one or two
like little hiccups but it was like a
second you know what i mean but it
mostly stayed through the whole four
hours so yeah and i'm not even
encouraging and i'm not even on the
wi-fi i'm on the satellite
yeah i'm not using i mean it's i don't
even know if it helps or not but it's
just like it's better safe than sorry i
kind of feel like yeah any little bit
off of that stream would help that's
what i'm saying and you know it's the it
is kind of rainy outside so we'll see
how it goes and i'm hopefully
hopefully uh everybody can hear us and
everything like that because like i said
i'm just i updated my obs and it's all
it has like new features and [ __ ] on it
and i'm just still trying to like figure
out how it works so how you doing
article how did uh did you everything
work out right at the hospital
when she hit the hospital yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh it went right already it did no
it went back no okay it came back yeah
don't make me nervous
oracle says i have not been drinking but
i'm on a lovely post-op painkiller
[Laughter]
she's got the good [ __ ] all right
well uh yeah so it's friday we don't
have anything
uh it's a sidetrack show we don't have
anything particular to talk about
never that's when i saw some good uh
videos last night hold on all right i
did want to address what camp guys said
earlier about the two grown men just
killed by a runaway camel at a tennessee
petting zoo
uh yeah camel's no joke that camel just
wasn't having it i guess he didn't want
to be petted anymore
so he's like
i mean it's not funny well i don't know
it kind of is funny but
it's it's kind of not funny i don't want
to be killed by a rampaging camel we're
good camels just saying
okay
last night i saw a good video it's uh
it's this one right here the publisher
is jesse michaels
that second one not 10 there
all right and it's called
the physics of ufos with eric weinstein
and hal put off
it's p-u-t-h-o-f-f
and it's a little hour-long program
and it's real good uh eric weinstein
he's a physicist he's
skeptical of like paranormal and ufo
type stuff
and uh hal put off was the guy who ran
the uh
the the stargate project with a remote
viewing project from uh for nsa and and
cia
and uh he was also part of that um
bigelow
bigelow aerospace and even did a couple
little studies
and um
he saw more of those tic tac videos you
know tic tac ufo videos he saw ones that
were shown to him by the navy that were
still classified
he didn't he said they were better says
those videos were a lot better he
wouldn't say what they were though
but um
he gets into um
a lot of the quantum consciousness stuff
from stuart hameroff and uh uh what's
the other guy's name um roger penrose
roger penrose and um he says that he
just gets into those topics and
weinstein is like man i i can't believe
you're
he's like
you're you're a scientifically rational
guy and you're you know what you're
talking about i can't believe you're
you're entertaining this you know what i
mean but he goes yeah and
part of it was he was talking about was
a faster than light travel
and that was kind of bending [ __ ]
weinstein's mind
because
when weinstein talked about it says
there's a couple experiments that were
pretty weird with electromagnetism where
it looked like electromagnetism
was uh doing things that were kind of
impossible when it came to like a stream
of protons he explains it
and um
basically what um what what house saying
is he's saying there's a lot of things
that you see
in these uh
tic tac and ufo type videos that the
government was showing the company that
he worked for because he was contracting
for him
he says can be explained with
certain things of the electromagnetism
and i couldn't grasp all of it you know
i mean these guys are [ __ ] much
smarter than me but and they have the
training for it
but he was saying that faster than light
travel is impossible
with the physics that they know
but you can take einstein's um
uh general relativity
and there are certain things that you
can do to make it appear that you
traveled faster than light
in other words a way to cheat
some and and he says it has
and they
they were saying that
part of it was is that we're only used
to
one
dimension of time moving forward in time
but theoretically there's a couple of
other dif a couple of other temporal
dimensions in other words
there's another future and another
future and another in a sideways future
which that you know kind of it doesn't i
can't imagine it but they can
um
kind of like i can only picture four fit
you know the three spatial dimensions
but they said no there's probably more
likes at least six of them
uh you know that's weird i've heard as
many as 11 yeah but again theoretical
yeah
but they did say that other dimensions
are kind of like some of these
theoretical dimensions kind of
merge
a direction in with time at the same
time in other words like a kind of a
fuzzy dimension where it's partly a
direction and partly a way of time is
flowing yeah so
but they were just saying purely purely
dimensional physical dimensions they
think that there should be six
so okay well our little brains are like
yeah
right right
well he started talking about hammer off
and then i went maybe go watch pembros
and hammer off they put a new video out
there talking to these
university students
and uh they're getting a lot better
uh feedback from them than they when
they first started talking about quantum
consciousness because now they were able
to prove a bunch of [ __ ] that's
happening in the microtubules of that of
the brain
there are phenomenon that's going on
going in there that does seem to be
quantum computation not so much like a
computer
it's an analog version because
well not an analog it's like a meta
material version that doesn't require
real low temperatures
and all this
they get into some wild [ __ ] but at the
very end of that show hamroff says
look i'm not we're not saying paranormal
phenomena exist
but if they do exist it's because of
this so you got to be real careful of
what they're saying i know what happens
that's what i've always said like look
there's probably way weirder [ __ ] out
there than we realized
but i don't think that it's like magic
or anything like that it's just some
[ __ ] that we don't understand yet that's
all just like everything else all that
stuff back in the old days they thought
electricity was packaging exactly so and
it's not
all that stuff that happened in mammoth
mountain all had to do with quantum
consciousness
uh rspk recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis but it's not psychokinesis
in the classic sense it appears to be
psychokinesis
it's some
something having to do with
quantum non-locality and [ __ ]
entanglement
uh and they understand it a lot better
than i do and i had it happen to me and
with witnesses
the reality is far stranger than you
think it is because there's more
dimensions involved than your senses can
interact with
but i recommend those shows right there
that's the physics of ufos with eric
weinstein and paul put off he gets into
remote viewing he doesn't he says paul
says he doesn't know how remote viewing
works they just know that they get
results about 70 percent
accuracy even won a bunch of money in in
las vegas using quantum they're not
quite using
kind of like remote viewing type stuff
which is
he explains it
uh it's
he doesn't know what to figure out how
to do that yeah he says he got tired of
winning money want to call uh 300 000
200 000
because i'm so sick of winning money
save is exhausted though so it was a lot
of work
because
it had something to do with choosing
random things and doing certain things
he
he talked about it
i can do [ __ ] with my brain that's fine
i'll do it for 300 dollars yeah the book
that book that that i read about uh it's
called psychic warrior
it was about that military remote
viewing program
the weird thing about it is that
they weren't getting results by going
into trances and seeing things some
dudes were but
in general what they were doing is
making objects and late putting labels
on objects and having other people
randomly pick them
and then
those objects had been had labels on
them that helped them narrow it down
what it was that they were looking for
and it seemed to be randomly generated a
guy would just randomly pick something
out of a bag and put it on the ground
and say okay so it's red you know that
kind of [ __ ]
yeah oh okay so it's they would just buy
a process of elimination narrow it down
so you're talking about an
unconsciousness
which goes into almost kind of like
what's that what was that [ __ ] um
freud's friend
um carl young carl young that there's
some kind of like a cosmic
unconsciousness
and that your unconscious is more
powerful than your consciousness and you
just unconsciously selecting things at
random
can lead you to
a conclusion that is accurate doesn't
make any sense to me but in the quantum
world it might in quantum mechanics it
might well yeah there might be some
connections that we're not aware of yeah
that's going on and they talk about it
in the end you know
used to be the [ __ ] college teams to
be booing them but now that they had
those damn results coming back
about them [ __ ] around with all the
uh anesthesia
they were proving that anesthesia is
working on the microtubules in the brain
they [ __ ] doped up these little
guppies and hit them with an ultraviolet
light it instantly knocked them all out
and they go okay that's what it is
we'll see but that's
that's good though because that's how
you have to approach scientific things
you have to be skeptical yeah until
somebody comes forward with